Ciao ragazzi Allora faccio Quest
brevissima introduzione al video perché
volevo ringraziarvi veramente di cuore
dei 60.000 iscritti Grazie mille e per
dimostrarvi il mio affetto farò
l'inchino più lungo del mondo Pronti
Via pessima idea ci ci Oh
[Musica]
Dio Salve youtubers Benvenuti ad una
nuova recensione prima di iniziarla
vorrei chiedervi una cosa perché mi
consigliate questi film che poi sono io
che me li devo guardare io che me li
devo recensire E io che mi sveglio la
notte urlando perché me li sogno mentre
voi ridete soltanto alle scene più
stupide vi odio il film che voglio
recensire oggi è the sisterhood
un horror del 2004 diretto
da David lecot ma dirmelo prima che l'ha
diretto lui questo film così evitavo di
guardarlo la trama del film è questa una
ragazza va al college e come in ogni
college che si rispetti ci sono le
confraternite di ragazze La
confraternita più famosa di questo
college si chiama B A T Bat ed è il
simbolo il suo simbolo è un pipistrello
e a quanto pare questa è la Come ho
detto prima La confraternita più famosa
Quindi questa ragazza farà di tutto per
entrare entrare Lì dentro la
protagonista ha un potere la tel cinesi
mentre il capo della confraternita è un
demone che si ciba di sangue di vergine
alla fine la protagonista riesce a
sconfiggere Questo demone Questa è la
trama super riassunta del film e vi
faccio un favore quindi vediamo insieme
quali sono i cinque punti per cui the
sisterhood ve lo dovevate Guardare
voi numero cin il regista David le
coteau che credo si pronunci così è un
regista strano sembra che faccia sempre
lo stesso genere di film cambiando solo
il titolo per esempio questa è la
locandina di sisterhood questa è quella
di The frightening questa quella di
witches of the Caribbean Questa è quella
di The Brotherhood Brotherhood 2 3 4 5
se O mio Dio ma fare un film un po'
diverso
no sparati sui Cagni sarà una recensione
terribile da
fare numero quatt sono già confuso di
solito non giudico un libro dalla
copertina tantomeno un film dalla
locandina ma in questo caso avrei dovuto
farlo il film inizia con due pomici
atori casuali in quella che sembra la
scena iniziale di un film porno da
quattro
soldi e questa è l'unica nota positiva
del film Quando ad un certo punto arriva
il cattivone di turno che in segue la
ragazza Oh ma quello è il tizio senza
faccia di
[Musica]
Freak corrono corrono corrono si
inseguono per tutto il tempo e finiscono
su un tetto
Oh perché mai scappando dovresti salire
su uno schifo di tetto tanto lo sai già
come andrà a
finire
appunto idiota e una cosa Eh perché
adesso il tizio è uno scheletro facciamo
finta di niente Facciamo finta di niente
andando avanti si vede la protagonista
che fa la sua prima lezione al college
conosce un ragazzo in classe vede un
pennarello volare e scrivere sulla
lavagna da solo scappa dalla classe
passano soltanto 20 secondi e già sono
super amicissimi dunque cosa abbiamo
compreso da tutto ciò che questo film ha
errori di continuità personaggi idioti
situazioni senza senso e dialoghi
raccapriccianti
Tu sei come me Vero sei seria
intendo non vorrei lasciarmi sfuggire
l'unica persona con cui ho qualcosa in
comune andiamo e il tutto in meno di 10
minuti mi sa che devo iniziare a
ignorare le vostre mail
tutte numero 3 super poteri Come ho
detto prima la protagonista ha un potere
e telecinese Ma non potete immaginare
come mostrano il suo potere Ma neanche
un topo da laboratorio sottoposto a
esperimenti radioattivi avrebbe potuto
mai pensare a quello che vi sto per
mostrare ora in una scena lei usa il suo
potere per spegnere una
candela
Wow farai faille geste di compleanno ma
andiamo avanti in un'altra scena
dimostra il suo potere facendo comparire
una colonna di luce Viola che la
colpisce coprendola di
glitter Ma questo non è neanche un
potere Questo è quello che succede se
unisci un My Little Pony con Edward Cen
di Twilight e poi questo il peggior modo
di usare un potere nella storia dei
poteri Adesso vorrei che
provassi a controllare i n
Cerca di fare in modo che si dispongano
su Due
[Musica]
Colonne Oh mio Dio spostare una fila di
numeri all'interno di un
computer Scusami eh tu sai cos'è questa
può fare esattamente quello che fai tu
con il tuo potere Ma posso anche spacc
partela sulla testa Quindi addirittura
molto più utile di te Stai attenta Oh
mio Dio nessuno ha mai fatto queste cose
e chissà perché magari perché è
completamente inutile sapete cosa io
inizio a pensare che i film che mi
consigliate voi Secondo me li fate
proprio voi soltanto per fare incazzare
me se dovessi scoprire un giorno che
quello che ho appena detto è
vero
numero due La confraternita come ogni
confraternita americana che si rispetti
prima di iniziare bisogna fare una
cerimonia che consiste nel farsi
manicure pedicure e
parrucchiere Sei sicuro che questa sia
la cerimonia per entrare in una
confraternita o vuoi solo diventare una
modella per Victoria Secret Comunque lei
passa il test ed entra a far parte del
gruppo e voi vi chiederete sacrificato
così tanto per far parte della
confraternità più in più cool di tutto
il college cosa si farà una volta dentro
semplice scene lesbo
Oh yeah e dopo quello altre scene lesbo
che bello o non fraintendetemi è un vero
piacere per gli occhi un po' meno per la
trama ma per gli occhi però se proprio
devi farmi vedere queste scene per 45
minuti almeno fai spogliare le attrici
No no
No ok ma ovviamente non fanno solo
questo le ragazze una volta Entrate
possono anche scegliere un uomo da
portarsi a letto Dimmi quale dei due
vuoi
avere lui e ti serve entrare in una
confraternita per fare quello ti basta
una
vagina per favore per favore se qualcuno
avesse visto il film ne dubito per
favore mi scriva se ha trovato il senso
a tutto quello che abbiamo visto fino
adesso Sono
disperato numero uno shock Il film dura
un'ora e mezza e siccome per una buona
ora non ci non ci hanno fatto altro che
vedere scene lesbo lo sceneggiatore
decide di buttarci addosso tutti i colpi
di scena possibili immaginabili in un
film state comodi e godetevi il viaggio
il capo della confraternita È
immortale tutte le ragazze della
confraternita sono dei
vampiri
la professoressa della protagonista è
una guardiana della
luce No io sono tuo
padre sono una
marionetta Ma non finisce qui grazie
alla combinazione dei poteri
telecinetici della protagonista e di un
paletto nel cuore della professoressa
riescono a f esplodere letteralmente
mente il nemico con degli effetti
speciali che ti fanno spappolare gli
occhi dalle
[Musica]
orbite per i motivi sbagliati ma
ovviamente non potrebbe essere un film
morrido se non ci fosse il canger finale
in una bara si porta sotto terra si
scopre che il nemico non è
morto No aspa un attimo ma non era
esplosa quella lì manco il cazzo di
finale riesco a mettere a posto neanche
un cliffhanger riescono a fare perché la
fai esplodere se poi è ancora intera
uccidila solo con il paletto anche se
effettivamente le esplosioni erano
talmente finte che non poteva morire
erano finte quindi questo era the
sisterhood Grazie mille per tutti gli
iscritti tutti i commenti Tutti i
complimenti tutte le magliette che
comprate tutto quanto Grazie mille
grazie infinite ancora per i 60.000
iscritti e noi ci vediamo ad una
prossima recensione